[Music]
you
all right so who here has heard about
webpack I hope so that's why you're here
right okay so yes my name is Shawn
Larkin I'm a program manager for
Microsoft in their web platform and I
work on edge dev tools but aside from
that I'm one of the maintainer of web
pack I kind of fall in line with the
developer advocate kind of role but then
I've also done some work on the angular
core team who here uses angular angular
okay yes nothing wrong with that there
isn't and just a general kind of
evangelist for open-source
sustainability a little bit about myself
so I'm kind of a former tech support rep
gone rogue I got tired of not being able
to solve people's problems and so I look
kind of learned to AppleScript whoever
has written an apple script before yeah
like that was my first programming
language and then I did a little bit of
objective-c Swift JavaScript and I do
like woodworking chicken farming
Internet of Things so yes like I said
sustainable open-source practices I've
been trying to be involved with
encouraging others to be involved with
open-source and how can you grow your
organization how can you grow your
community how can you make it rich and
thriving so you can find me at the lark
in so feel free you know you can take a
look and see me at any of these places
online yeah hi my name is Tobias copass
and I'm the founder of epic and
maintainer and part of the core team and
yeah and go ahead and yeah currently I'm
doing full-time open source web
development and next yeah you just tell
me what I'll do it no it won't work from
this far there we go cool and my
background is a little bit weird for a
Yahveh script developer I'm started with
C sharp C++ C development and did
JavaScript as a hobby and yeah so I came
to make
but I've never done a real web
application so far never made a real web
application what yeah you also find me
on github and on Twitter because so
course I did a W it's cool why not okay
so yes we're gonna talk about a lot of
things today I mean and a lot of it is
gonna be about web pack of course hold
on so on a side note Tobias
when you wrote web pack it was for not
four years thesis right it was for the
web project that your thesis was for I
did a web project in my thesis oh and
but it's small one okay and yeah that's
I need of epic module bandar and it
started with a pull request on and to
another project
yep make and but it was rejected to
prove request so because it was a
complete rewrote of the language and so
I published as another name modules web
pack yeah and it was renamed to epic yes
so wasn't even forest thesis project
just shutting some light there so yes
but we're gonna talk about not only how
web pack works under the hood I'm gonna
kind of get so who here has like never
actually configured their web pack
before we love create react app we love
everything that you know we we like
being able to write code when we need to
there are some people out there who love
configuring or you know have very unique
kind of scenarios and that's why web
pack exists so we're also going to talk
about just the high level understanding
how web pack works from the user
interface and then we're gonna talk
about how it works under the hood and
what we have coming for you for web pack
for so who knows what a JavaScript
module is yeah okay cool yep sure why do
we like them because they're reusable
they're encapsulated
organized for the most part I mean
unless you have like a Redux and
reactants like everything's like spread
out everywhere they're convenient but
what do they look like well you have
common Jas if you're just familiar with
it just raise your hand when you see the
module type that you you've used before
common Jas yes
AMD yeah mg plus common Jas I will be
wow I've never seen this before until
like I made this slide and then we have
typescript or Equus script module syntax
pretty similar pretty similar should I
shake the dongle so it there we go
excellent luckily beyond it and issue a
free stage yeah we're on the issue free
stage yeah yeah submit an issue okay
we'll get back to you so how do they
work in the browser well they don't
really or if they do not very well or
not very fast maybe soon and every
library is different like wouldn't it
you know if you go and MPM installer
look at your package saw JSON
every single library might ship a
different format of these modules and
it's up to them and this is just
JavaScript that we're talking about it's
not even talking about other things like
styles assets images PNG etc so wouldn't
it be nice if it all just worked
together seamlessly
and sweat pack that is what wet vac is
so you all know wet pack is module
bundler but I like reinforcing the idea
what does this mean it lets you write
modules that work in the browser that
simple was that probably the main
premise tobias you'd say like that was
the point this was a point but also code
splitting was my intention that's right
code splitting that's right that's right
from modules web make and if you wanted
to know about that story check out or
read me at the bottom of the readme so
just gonna blaze through kind of the
since most people understand how to use
it so we have our config we have a CLI
which literally uses the node API behind
the scenes and then we have the node API
itself and so this is the core concepts
I'm just so that you can understand
before we dive under the hood how it
works kind of on top of the hood so we
have our entry point let's say given you
have a module and it relies on you know
another component and then that
component probably relies on a couple
more components you know you're
importing and requiring them whatever
syntax but that one has a dependency
it's a common jeaious library let's say
and but wait it also it's like bootstrap
or something else they have style
dependencies in one way or another that
is our entry that is the entry point
when we talk about entry and webpack the
root of that graph is what we're
referring to and so it is the first
javascript in your project to kick off
your application so you can kind of see
here when you define your entry point
web pack literally says how ok let's
start at this this file will resolve it
and then we're gonna trace through here
and go through each of these pieces to
make sure so we're basically telling
what to load for the browser and it
works with the output property of course
so output that's another core concept so
you can think about it exactly what its
purpose is by defining specific
properties like a path and a filename
we're telling webpack how to handle
these files so in this case we've
created a bundle output it to a folder
and there's way more properties that you
can define an output but that's the
high-level idea
it's treatment of the dependency graph
when it is created so loaders this is
like one of my favorite part like good
idea loaders were a great idea to us so
not every dependency is gonna just be
JavaScript but we want to explicitly tie
them together so loaders allow you to
tell web pack how to treat non
JavaScript after it's been resolved so
let's say you have a type script file or
JavaScript that doesn't really the
syntax doesn't make sense or it's newer
yes it's something that's not supported
by our traditional parser or let's say
it's CSS or style so you can kind of
imagine in that same diagram that we use
that it is tracing through these
dependencies and before we add it to the
graph these functional transforms are
converting this into a JavaScript module
in some representation and there's all
sorts of flexibility behind it we can
filter through them like how many no
commonly you know a good practice or
something we see a lot in the react
community is that you ignore your no
modules or exclude them who has seen
that before probably good share hands
yep so lots of different options to
filter through and it's incredibly
flexible so much that you can even chain
it together so let's say if you have
something like less well the traditional
idea or foundation is that you want to
have a loader that performs one
operation so one transform and then you
can chain them together so if you have a
less file you'll see here it converts it
to a style dot CSS converts it to like
an array in memory of the style and that
pretty much what it is like an array and
then then we get this JavaScript module
called inline that style into the
browser with style tags
best way to say it but there's literally
a million different options that are out
there in our ecosystem and this is my
favorite part because a loader is just a
function that takes a source and returns
a new source it's so easy to create and
publish and share and and have this
really rich ecosystem that we have for
our project so loaders tell us webpack
how to interpret and translate files
especially that aren't JavaScript and
they kind of return compilations they
return new sources so plugins who is
ever written a custom plugin yes like I
may be this like first five minutes is
too boring for you this is the anatomy
of a plugin so I like to define it as a
class to be as always correct me and
says it's an instance so it's just an
object that has an apply method on the
prototype chain and so you can see here
this is the anatomy and so what we have
is that whenever the whenever this
plug-in is registered webpack will call
apply plugins and it will pass an
instance of itself into this plug-in so
that hooks can be hooked into and then
functionality performed so in this case
this is super simple
whenever the compiler is done or it is
failed we're literally going to write a
dinging noise to the terminal so now
that you kind of understand it looks
like a class it kind of has a
constructor how does it operate so when
you use it in your configuration you're
passing a new reference to it and then
that way if you have options let's say
some of the more common chunks plug-in
let's wiggle it there we go
ship it you can pass additional
arguments options and features to be a
Suntech here but did you know that 80%
of web pack is made up of its own
plug-in system did you know that yes
my gosh this was my response when I
found this out for the first time the
Blake screen huh oh you can hear that
was kind of my mind was like no way oh
that was a nice image to be as I like
that okay no worries no worries so we
know that essentially plugins add
additional functionality to web packs
event lifecycle and so it gives you the
power to do anything that you ever
wanted to and so this kind of takes me
to the next part of this talk which is
like the main guts so who's feeling kind
of comfortable so far you're like okay
okay Shawn tell me how it really works
how does it work under the hood so the
next part of this talk is we're gonna
now completely remember everything that
I just told you but don't try to tie it
together with these concepts so we're
gonna talk about how web pack works
under the hood as an architecture as a
system as a bundler but before we begin
we're gonna talk about something called
Kappa Bowl who here knows what a bowl is
ok cool somebody's writing some plugins
so tappa Bowl is this 200 line library
235 I think to be exact
not anymore but it is the backbone of
the web pack plugins system the whole
architecture is based on this library so
what was Sean what does that even mean
so tappa bowl allows you to mix mix in
with an existing class and then it
magically is bestowed these awesome
functions like apply plugins parallel or
apply plugins async or apply plugins and
what that does is these are the events
that get emitted that plugins are
listening to so who here is ever used
nodes event emitter ok tap a pool is
very very similar so you can see here
that there is literally an event and
then in this case it's because it's an
async event we allow the plug-in to
perform functionality call a callback
and
we continue so here's a super super
basic plug-in you saw it once before of
course I like writing them as classes
because it makes more sense to me but we
have a constructor and then the only
rule is that it has to have an apply
function or a method or property on the
prototype chain and that way we had we
gain access when we register this plugin
to the compiler itself and then we are
going to listen to the event and do
something so in the same way my
beautifully drawn slides one we apply
and we gain access to the compiler then
when webpack runs or when something that
uses the system runs it then triggers
these hooks so you might be like Sean
what do you why you keep saying capital
instance or you might hear it a few
times all that means is a class or an
object that extends Tafel or really
something that you can plug into so
another diagram might be this is very
specific to webpack is that to access
the compilation which is another
instance we have to plug into or tap
into the compiler first and then as you
can see here the compilation also has
lots of different plugins that are
executing different functionality so
we're gonna talk about what are these
seven capital instances so compiler is
the first one it's kind of the I say
central dispatch it's kind of like start
and stop it really delegates the
top-level events that are happening when
webpack runs or finishes and it's
exposed via the node API and then we
have the dependency graph so the
compilation there we go I kind of call
it's like the brain everything that's
super juicy about what webpack does
happens inside of the compilation it's
created by the compiler and it contains
our dependency graph traversal algorithm
that's such a mouthful basically how we
collect and create the dependency graph
and then we have the resolver so who
here is ever used or understands what a
resolver is okay so don't get like
scared by the name all resolver does is
it resolves it finds things it just
finishes so let's say for example when
you use a shorthand syntax for a path in
node the nodes native resolver gives you
the absolute path and verifies it exists
so in the same way here with webpack our
module Factory might be given this
partial path to let's say an entry point
or a an import statement and then the
resolver just says okay let me go find
out and make sure it works or it exists
then when it's done it actually will
return a lot of extra information like
what folder was this file in what's the
absolute path what was the raw request
etc and as you can see here it is tappa
belanzone bs basically came up with
almost every single plug-in that you
could think of that you would need to
make this as configurable as possible
okay so now we have module factories so
who here so I know the angular users out
there who's like I know what a factory
is people know what a factory is all it
does is return objects or something and
so in this case we have a module factory
that takes a resolved request and then
it collects the source for that file now
that we know it exists and we know where
it is and it creates a module object out
of it Wow look it's so beautiful and it
goes through the factory there and then
we have the parser so who is ever
written a parser who knows what an ast
is who's written a babble plug-in okay
so you all in some way have been exposed
to an AST so parser parses it will
convert raw source code into a tree
called an AST that can be easily
traversed
and so what webpack does is we parse the
file and then we extract all of the
dependency statements so requires
imports etc there we go and then we
create these things called dependencies
or dependency objects so if I was to
diagram this we take this module object
that we've received and we pass it
through our little glasses that are
parsing and then we add dependencies to
our module and then we have the template
so who here is used a template before in
UI you know in your UI code we all know
what the purpose of a template is it's
for binding data to your view well in
this case for webpack we're just binding
data to the source code of the code that
we're going to generate or the modules
in this case you can kind of think of it
like the configuration is our props the
dependency graph is our state and our
template is like the JSX
so it creates code that you see in your
bundles so if I was going to diagram
this if we look here we have a template
for every single kind of abstraction so
a chunk which is just a container to
keep reference to our modules in our
graph that is gonna have a template our
module has a template in each flavor of
these dependencies are gonna have
templates I just use like handlebars to
describe this and then when we call
render out pops what you see in a web
pack like in a bundled file so let's
recap what we've just learned so if we
started out with the entry we're gonna
read the entry point that we got from
the entry property and it's going to go
through and verify that it exists so
we're going to the resolver and then
once we verified we're gonna get this
normal module object and web pack is
gonna pass that to the parser and if
it's not JavaScript that's when we pass
loaders against it
and if it is JavaScript we're gonna
collect dependencies and attach them to
that module but we don't know if those
dependencies actually exist and so we
have to resolve them and this entire
cycle repeats until the graph is
complete to be as check my work does
that sound accurate so yes that is
exactly so now how does this dependency
graph get into the browser
so I wrote this comic I drew this comic
hi I'm a module I can't wait to work in
the browser oh cool your jets we need to
get you into shapers you need to jump in
this thing we call a chunk and we need
to keep track of you because you were
gonna crap ton of plugins at you we
don't want to lose track all right
almost there but we have a problem those
require statements have to go and but
the parser gave us some special
instructions called templates and a
factory so that we can replace them
Wow I'm finally ready for browser land
look at this thank you so you just
learned how web pack entirely works
under the hood entirely entirely so how
do we feel comfortable about this so far
yes kind of okay excellent
that's good that's more hands that I've
seen before excellent so now that I've
kind of talked about everything that you
know is to know in terms of our
architecture I want to give Tobias the
opportunity now to talk about what are
we going to do for web pack 4 so you
understand how it works
you understand the concepts so what are
we going to do to make like how are we
going to make this even more powerful
yeah thanks yeah thank you
and yep but have you changing it because
it's a bit bad that we always use
strings in the
long method names and just weird and the
most the biggest problem is its
unperformed to use strings and it's not
monomorphic and so we are changing it
and to a new syntax and but it's
transparent for the user if you don't
only use their packets you don't see it
yes
but the new some text like this and or
more fake books and better performance
then people can get typings well yeah
yeah yeah you can even get type analysis
why you read a plug-in quite a plugin
you can see all the plug-in hoops we
have this typing's
that somebody really create hopefully it
mean of yes I spent a little bit of time
on the plane but it was kind of
difficult so yeah okay okay we editing a
new feature which basically currently we
have the one time always in the first
chunk and it's it m2 lot other chunks
you have to have the one time in suppose
and this is a bit unclear because you
can't use I think script X because order
is important you have to lots of one
time first and then the spirit chunks
and so we're changing this to a pattern
which is also used by some other things
which is we create a okay and push to
the array so it's order and dependent
and you can use a Singh script X which
have a lot of benefits yes example if
you have the main or the vendor chunk
cached
or the comments on cached and other
chunks not then it can be related before
other things and it's not help don't
have to wait for the M so it chunks
defined before I'm says how do you make
HTML I think you're good examples like
I've seen people try and do multiple
Commons chunks but that can create
dependent chunk dependencies and
sometimes the order can be not as
expected but this solves that problem
yeah okay yeah so and we also adding
very big change is that we allow other
module types and JavaScript so we want
to have native support for
webassembly example and we also add with
the same pattern and native support for
CSS because it's currently CSS is a bit
of a heck with extract explained
extremely really big so you get native
CSS support which means also that you
get and separate CSS file by default and
all the fancy stuff in separate CSS
files and you don't know long I have
injected the CSS code into the script
bundle and you don't have to double pass
it so that's better and webassembly
school so you'd say so now that you kind
of understand how web pack works under
the hood we can kind of explain what
this means so when you saw our template
our module factories our runtime our
parser it's all centric around
JavaScript and that's it and so for the
work that we're gonna have to do is put
an abstraction layer it's ok you can go
all the way back there friend yeah like
even the templates it doesn't matter but
essentially what this will do we now can
have the opportunity to put an
abstraction layer on it and make X as a
first class citizen and so you might see
new wasum templates ym runtimes
a wise em resolver a wizened parser and
so we want to be able to provide and
create the same opportunities like code
splitting scope poisoning and everything
that's possible for Azzam and javascript
and CSS or even HTML modules in the
future who's that with this yep
ok and oh yeah this example for the
vaasam stuff is very cool so - you can
just import synchronously import
embossing module and repect take care of
the a synchronous compiling and loading
of the bottom part
it basically hoisted to the next chunk
loading so if you load a chunk which
contains vassal modules it will launch a
chunk in parallel to compiling and
annoying the awesome stuff in it yeah
so why yeah the
and I always ask why can't we just use
Waze I'm rust C++ just like a JavaScript
module and so that was our goal and you
know of course we were awarded a grant
for $125,000 by Mozilla to implement
this work so we're super excited to get
this out to you guys and we're working
with teams like v8 chakra core to be
able to ensure that these LLVM tool
chains are nice and fast and work really
well with webpack to allow you to do
things like this but it's a long way and
yes we probably take a year to have good
support for native languages the
co-pilot infrastructure need to be
adjusted and Laura's for West and C++ so
it's taken away but my pick for we'll
start with basic support module yep so
and we always seen this in the mainstage
and on us yeah so and you basically get
better optimization for big libraries
which contains many modules like lodash
or here's example with X so the problem
this is pattern and you import some
French a function from Lotus but the
ACMA suppt spec says every side effect
in this lodash library must be executed
so and because the other side is a bit
wonky
it's not the active I epic isn't sure
about is this a side effect or is it
just a prototype way a method to it and
it's not used so and with this pattern
you currently get big bundles yep
because many side effects executed and
so epic will introduce a new and package
level and flag which is called side
effects Falls so we basically opt in to
say epic yeah my modules don't have side
effects so if you import them and you
don't use the exports
you can admit them so and basically Pepa
classes and if you write something like
that
it follows we export and basically
rewrite it to own to include only the
module which contains the flatten
function mm-hmm
so that way you know we should see out
of the box so we're working with package
authors like lo - and I'm working with
teams who have open source projects like
react fabric UI and Microsoft as well as
rxjs and the angular team to ensure that
this can be something that will be
available and possible immediately when
we release my pack Ford so you can use
it we want to ensure that there are huge
winds out of the box for you just by
updating to web pack for and I believe
there's also probably going to be a
whitelist property - right yeah it's
planned currently it's only supported to
have a flat flag for the coil package
but tip it's plan to have modules
specifying something like nice only is
this files but not I guess we sure and
Jade JD daltonism is on my team at
Microsoft and so he's super excited to
see this - yes also change a bit in the
process for the next released least
calidad and a week after that released
sceles and it was unfortunate because
they also complained about it's too fast
now we can't just keep our can fix our
code and so we give them more time a
month between release candidate and
released em so maybe with this release
most plugins and loaders are compatible
yes yeah absolutely we we listen to you
know anytime that we try and ship fast
you know we we end up hearing from our
package authors or dependent authors and
so we decide okay well we'll find out
from the ecosystem how we want to
release a breaking change and so we
typically say two to three months and
then we'll give module authors a chance
by
having an RC for a month so that they
can make sure they can catch up report
bugs etc so you should see a benefit for
the ecosystem in that when you upgrade
to web pack for even though they're not
my there may not be that many breaking
changes that it you know whatever
dependency or if you're writing a
package or a plugin for it that you can
have time to test it before release so
yes is that the last slide I can't guess
so excellent that's beautiful that's it
so yes if you guys have any questions of
course we can't do Q&A now but feel free
to stop by either of us and say hi or
anything literally webpack is created by
you so every person here who came to
support us at this stage we thank you so
much and so thank you guys
[Applause]
it's a chance to answer to give some
questions oh we do have questions
awesome one more question yes okay so
could you please advise how to dine it
oh so I guess if you do have some
questions you can ask them so how do you
dynamically include chunks file name if
rendering a page via JSX template on
server side do you want to take their
own yeah you basically need to take the
chasing stats file it's there are some
plugins to write it to a file epic
starts plug-in also many plugins and
this file contains all the information
about how the structure of the epic
panelist and also the chunks file names
in some there's a mapping with name
touch filename and to just read them
wait this file and you get this so
hopefully that answers your question
wins wins way back for ready I mean so
we have Tobias always says when it's
done but I think so we still have some
things that we need to finish but we
never give a solid timeline we do
promise that we won't release something
within two or three months of the
previous major release but if you want
to try it out now that gives you an
opportunity to really report bugs and
help us feel good about shipping the RC
faster so if you check out the project
on github it's under the next branch
right now and so I tested it you know on
the plane and before like the week
before and in most of the basic cases it
was working pretty well so yes you
probably some beta versions before and
so you get the feeling when it's near
would you use webpack as a static site
generator would you yes I would and why
not there are there are some site
generators which use web pick add-ons I
don't know the names
five phenomena Gatsby yeah I know knocks
Jas but that kind of isn't truly static
but yeah can a CSS file be the entry
file it can be but it's not recommended
you basically you shouldn't put the
state
you shouldn't separate the styling from
the JavaScript stuff you should have an
entry point to your application which is
in dependency graph of all your
dependency you have a script end styling
so you just if you if you many people
just says have an entry for a Yahveh
script and have an entry for styling but
this is kind of an old pattern which
Tosca knows but in repick you the idea
is to have a complete dependency graph
of all styling and script any early
advance for web pack 5 well I mean we
try not to think about the next version
until we've really been comfortable
while shipping what we've set out to for
web pack for so I mean so most of the
time I mean up until we started hearing
feedback like guys don't ship majors so
fast we get scared and so like okay so
what we decide is that we'll wait two
three months and what we'll do is any
breaking changes that provide
performance or any other features will
hoist into like we'll just kind of keep
it suspended in our github and then
those will land into web pack the next
major version whatever it is it's
probably gonna be awesome
yes Azzam yeah assembly support very
likely that you'll see that in web pack
5 why is module concatenation disabled
by default
yeah it's inverse an experiment and it's
basically in experimental state status
and we edit it in Depok for anything so
and we can't it would be a breaking
change to enable it by default and then
in a major version but am i planning
maybe to
do some refactoring with optimization
and separation between production and
development stuff in the epic form maybe
there's a optimization production
optimization the development flag which
you can set and then you get always a
good stuff for production and all that
stuff yeah and when you think about it
like it is a production feature only so
like don't use it on your dev server
don't use it with HMR it's broken with
HMR I'm pretty sure yeah I mean like the
point is is that we can't assume that
you have a production or developing
environment we can't assume anything
that's what makes web pack so powerful
to use is because you have the ability
to make it work for your stack so if we
were to put that on by default
everybody's builds would be inherently
slower at the cost you know for us it's
easier for us to have a feature that's
available for you to opt in and not make
any assumptions what best practices
should we follow for the best code
minification what plugins how to import
etc that's a good question it's well
yeah yeah a neighbor module Kinnickinnic
concatenation a neighbor and he was
Bobby with module spoils he was code
splitting and active file compiler
Babel preset EMV is also really good
advice if you are using Babel because
it's going to look and see what it's
basically autoprefixer for your
JavaScript and so you pass the browsers
that you support if you only support one
browser then there may be a likely
chance that you don't have to minify or
I'm sorry transpile all of the different
syntaxes that you're using so should an
external flag dependency be a peer
dependency or a normal one so like in
externals if they're doing like a
library package that doesn't care about
this yeah it depends if you a peer
dependency is something you your library
in example if you if you have a plug-in
or something like that for other project
and it's a
P depends because you want to give the
user the opportunity to choose the
library and you as a plugin for the
library or you can specify which range
as possible dependencies and you
basically get always gets the latest
version you are in your veins yeah is it
good to use webpack for node and express
my opinion
yes absolutely um one of the things that
like we haven't gotten enough like intel
on is like when you bundle a node app
it's sometimes faster because the module
resolution in your noggin be a little
slow so yeah and so like when you bundle
a node app it's kind of faster and you
instantly can use ESM syntax so no dot
MJS know any of this crazy stuff you can
literally just bundle a node app and
anybody here use hot module replacement
for their api's or like yeah it is a
really nice feature super nice you can
literally update your code without
having to like close out your server
restart it you know check the API to see
if it works it's just instant when you
update your code so yeah can you give us
some webpack t-shirts I have a huge so I
do have a bunch but they're like extra
large and XXL so I but I do have a bunch
back in the hotel room so like
throughout the day you can probably find
me and we can get those for you yeah is
there any plan to start using typescript
or flow for web pack it makes easier for
more people to contribute so this part
is your opinion only that's your opinion
only and so you can't really speak for
everybody who's a contributor but is
there a plan so it's really hard there's
like a lot of different reasons that we
don't want to
I'll let Tobias speak to his I think one
it's really it is a complete like we'd
have to completely change our
architecture and we've never ever in
webpack had to have a build step for our
library and so there's a lot of benefits
like being able to instantly link or
allow people to check out from github
and not have to do any builds up or
anything like that or shipping a disk so
and I know you have opinions like about
the code style that gets transpiled and
things yeah and basically it's if you
write a code directly you basically see
what the performance is and if you have
a translation step you maybe sometimes
you don't see always this is very
expensive to use and for off loop with
the transpire to a complex pattern you
can generate assessing functions or
something like that so this performance
could be performance problems you know
don't see it obviously and we don't want
to choose one flow or typescript yeah
it's kind of like a that's kind of a
controversial decision for us to like we
we believe that both systems are great
but we also don't want to make an
opinion on them and you know cause an
issue in our ecosystem we care more
about that then it comes to the
structure and typing's and really once
we have this new plug-in system and we
have typing's generated for it you're
gonna see a lot especially through like
vs code a considerable amount of type
support and intellisense while
contributing in our project so it should
be a much more elevated experience than
what it used to be how much work will be
required to update from web pack three
to four an existing project not too bad
and so far there are no change bacon
changes for the user it's only four
plug-ins internal changes and so so if
you use upgraded to the new epic force
and it should basically just replace the
parent sees and I I guess currently
there's no big changes the configuration
maybe we add some chopped tomatoes
we'll find something I'm sure like
there's always sneaking changes but we
we have a M for two to three we have an
upgrade guide and we continue this with
an upgrade guide for the user which
contains all the changes you need with
quotes examples and so yep oh this is a
fun one DLL plug-in verse comments chunk
plug-in would you recommend we picked
this one by the way in case you're
curious would you recommend for codes
footing in web pack
or it feels like three questions I'm not
sure
so I mean both of them do completely
separate things so like dll plug-in if
you understand how external works it's
basically telling webpack don't try and
resolve this file just know that when
this code is actually in the runtime or
in the browser that this whatever is set
as your external will be available and
so a dll plugin just creates a bundle of
these externals so you can link together
with another build yeah I guess if you
do a vendor chunk they basically do is
the same thing but they have different
benefits and DL packing is faster but
you don't get tree shaking or scope
hoisting in the deal but with the
comments Shanklin to basically say
common chunk only contains exports and
modules we really use in your
application so it's tree-shaking its
scope posted and so it's smaller so as
yeah it's kind of the trade-off so like
I always tell people use dll plugin in
development mode because you're avoiding
work of bundling time so like your
builds we faster but don't use it in
production you can but those are the
trade-offs that he just gave an example
for what are the best practices for
using webpack for large code bases how
do you improve build time so that's one
of the things we mentioned so dll plugin
is a great example we actually so like
we have an entire like page that I think
you even authored it yourself so if you
go to web pack touch a set org slash
guides you're gonna see a build time
guide and Tobias authored it this is one
of the things take a look at your
resolve property like now understanding
how resolvers work you essentially add a
lot of extra build time by having really
eloquent or complex resolve properties
I'm sure you can give advice is
expensive one is Laura's so it can
optimize server solving this less
extensions like less motivated to use
and the Laura you can optimize for say
there's a cache loader and a sweat Laura
bubble has a cache directory flag which
caches results and basically caching
it's important in the other side and
yeah yeah and could you explain the
difference between loader we just told
you the difference who didn't know that
no that's okay
so I'll try and simplify it what's the
difference between a loader and a plot
yeah we can we can toss that if you know
if you're still not comfortable come
find me and I'll spend as much time
explaining how it works why don't we do
this one I like this one
can we can we choose or do we have to do
the thumbs up I want to talk about
roll-up okay yeah what do you think it's
great about roll-up so for me I love it
because it's focused when you have
constraints you can focus on doing
something really well and so in this
case building bundling the library is
great using roll-up you can give your
comments yeah it's you don't doesn't
include just scope hoist all the modules
and if it works with scope rising it's
great
and for most libraries you can use it
because you have control over the code
and then it's super minimum and readable
output files and web pack it's more
about optimized and non readable output
files and includes one time because the
comments a chair staff and other non
ACMA script module stuff so it's
basically replicates have to fulfill a
broad of age of dependencies and weird
formats and so it's it's optimized yeah
and like I said like high level like
when you can focus on something
constraint you can do it really well and
so roll up is really good for bundling
libraries and we always recommend it
thanks for webpack can you talk about
the contributor community thank you for
using it I mean we would be nothing
without you you are the contributor
community something that we like to say
is like it was a tweet from somebody you
said like stop thinking that you're just
buying our product but you're another
member of our you know our community and
that's who that's what we think and so
thank you I would say our contributor
community
has exploded in the past like three
months we've had people from all over
the world who has contributed to webpack
here like we even have people here today
thank you so much like we would not be
where we are today Yap let's give them a
round of applause like thank you we
would be nothing without you and like we
also have guides and things on how to
contribute different ways you can check
out our medium publication under
contributors guide and we have it you
know I've written a two blog post and I
should get the other ones out but on how
to contribute and what things to look
for cuz to us it's you take the things
that you love to do you take what you're
good at and how you bring value and then
that's your purpose for our project and
so we want you to work on things that
you love it doesn't have to be code it
can be documentation can be tack writing
it could be focusing just on error
messages if you love working on error
messages we want you to do it it doesn't
matter
you could have zero years of experience
you could have 20 years of experience
you could be a c-sharp developer who
wrote construction CT machines for a
living until he started doing open
source full-time it doesn't matter so
please please please if you're
passionate about webpack or you want to
be involved let us know well webpack be
open source always sure yes always be a
part of the chase foundation and the
terms with Chase Foundation make sure
that my pegs will always be always
possible for us to make it yep not even
possible let's how much time are we we
still have time for quests oh okay well
angular CLI work instantly with white
pack for ask the CLI team I know I'm on
it but I haven't be as involved likely
yes it should will webpack for support M
script and generated Waze and modules
out-of-the-box like I think they're
talking about a wasum library target
like a wasum Lib
target or is it talking about like just
a pure wasm module I
it's about the difference between
between Rossum modules and vaasam
Mateusz for M's Krypton because I'm
scripting does some web JavaScript and
basically it has a full linking step
with step and oh yeah okay put the whole
thing in Superman vo more more about em
separating each compilation its each C++
file into a Russian module and make the
dependency graph in Bassem and I'm
captain basically gives a big big big
chunk of bottom code which is generated
by the whole code base so when CSS
becomes a first class citizen in webpack
4 will webpack dev server ha
reload CSS files directly instead of a
blob URL what do you think case maybe
yes
so case is actually also a maintainer of
web pack and works on web pack dev
server so I pulled them up yeah yeah you
can make it a yes or no answer or like
maybe it doesn't matter I think that'd
be good I like it yes yes is your answer
I'm sorry for pulling you up on the spot
but I just want to be want you to be up
here because it's not technically not a
perfect observer by question because so
with reloading ones over there how to do
replacement stuff and it's not yes yes
exactly
so using resolver for paths IDE doesn't
see them could we expect to plug-in for
it yeah you just learned how to make a
plug-in
okay so you can reach out to us if you
want advice or ideas or how-to or maybe
if your V s code user like myself we
would love a resolver language service
how cool would that be do resolve alias
to slow down the build is there an
optimal amount to use and be fine there
isn't
I mean don't use as many but I would say
what do you think the least slow resolve
configuration is alias only does stream
compare and then it's basically it
doesn't introduce extra IO build so
that's a the most performant option you
can use but I guess I was a backhoe pod
about somebody made ten thousand alias
configurations and it's oh my gosh yeah
so don't do that that's not even
practical okay so is what pack for gonna
support basic stuff for web assembly or
are you going to be adding advanced
extra features as well yeah we want to
add extra features but and epic for
focus on the basic features because we
want to get something out it's basic
Rossum support to see how the crowd
reacts and yeah like how it worried like
does it work and how well does it work
is it successful so thank you guys for
all these are tough some really cool
questions those are really cool like
service so awesome thank you guys so
much you can find us afterwards
[Applause]
you